i was in la jolla two weeks ago
great shows san diego left there to go
skiing with ahri shane gillis uh ian
fyden
we got a house how was it it was amazing
just we did shrooms every night that's
why i'm like under the weather we did
shrooms every night we drank every night
we skied all day we cooked laughing
snapping towels hot tub rolling around
the snow headlocks great time we had a
big steak dinner the last night me and
shane gillis are pounding white claws on
the ski lift you know good times is you
guys watching pam and tommy or what is
it i have a dice isn't it dice is great
dice is really good who's he play he's a
mob guy is he yeah he plays the mob guy
that's uh he's always good always good
kills it he loaned the uh the guy who
stole the tape he loaned him the money
that he needed to
make the copies and distribute it do you
know him do you guys know each other i
opened for him once and it it was a
little uh awkward why well i was excited
you know he's a legend whatever so i go
up to him before the show and i you know
i'm gonna ask i'm gonna let him know i'm
the opener ask how much time he wants
and i go hey mr dice don't want to
bother you my name is mark i just want
to know how much time and he goes do you
want a photo and i go oh no i don't i
don't need a photo i just want to know
how much day goes you're nervous aren't
you and i'm like no no i'm just asking
how much time do you want me to do when
he goes come here give me a call
and he makes me take a photo
that was it i walked away and i never
got the time
that's funny that's gotta be yeah you're
nervous dice is doing bits yeah
that's very funny oh was that his own of
course
he hates taking pictures with people
with the comic you would do it oh that's
hilarious yeah he had the best crowd
ever like you could say anything yeah
they're awesome yeah they were great
yeah yeah did you watch that's good of
course i mean he commands that stage
it's crazy it's a presence always new
material always vicious and funny yeah
he's still really hilarious yeah and
then at the end of the it was it a rock
fest or was it rock on the range i think
it's cold okay yes yeah in um ohio ohio
yeah so after i think one of these big
bands giant bands i can't remember who
was playing at the end of the big arena
that was like the big finale and they
invited him on stage and he did the
nursery rhyme and the whole audience is
saying it with him and it was i got
chills that's awesome it was great
that's right i wonder who brought them
on it was one of those guns and roses
right no not that big but it was uh you
know like a like a good charlotte or a
okay something like that
yeah he opened for guns and roses i
think at the hollywood bowl it was like
a hundred thousand people wow back in
like the late 80s or early 90s that
might have been it right there oh the
18th
good gig i've done that once it's a
really good gig super fun gig that's
awesome love a fest
yeah i uh yeah i've been watching the
pam and tommy show i get frustrated that
it's
not just all in one shot
that they're putting the episodes out
week by week yeah that's annoying why is
that why is that bad it's annoying like
i want to just knock it out yeah i want
to knock the whole thing off where are
they doing it what uh hulu oh [ __ ]
hulu
all they do is [ __ ] my subscriptions
are never good oh your subscription
doesn't cover these channels what am i
paying for
oh because you're trying to get the live
tv channels whatever i want to watch is
always a [ __ ] issue right i've had
pretty good experience with hulu i had a
terrible experience yeah pretty i paid
for the no ads
you know felt like a big big shot
because it's you guys are chumps i steal
cable i've got i get everything 13 bucks
i get everything
i'm talking everything you got hulu do
you have the live tv hulu i got all that
i got a live tv i got the fights i got i
need to do it i can show you after okay
oh oh you're actually stealing
i'm stealing the whole
caboodle enchilada
i paid 13 i get every single thing i can
watch i've got dean martin roast from
the 50s it's all on there on youtube
yeah
or wherever yeah you name it you got vpn
i don't know if it's vpn i know i don't
even i don't know anything about it i
pay a guy it's real shady
and i get everything and then if it's
not on there i can text him and go hey
[ __ ] where's the new whatever
special and he goes up i'll have it up
in an hour wow that's pretty good what a
system i know it's like the 90s let's go
to lou she has a very important question
uh-oh okay what's up blue this is
wheelchair little hi hey how are you
good how are you doing uh louise is your
name oh nevermind no
no
luanne
lou oh lou
okay hey hey lou you're here
hey look um mark i was wondering if
you're gonna invite seinfeld to your
wedding
[Music]
you know
it crossed my mind but
it's a good way to text him but uh that
rejection i don't know if i could handle
it you have to invite him really of
course you're friends with him i mean
look
he hates weddings he's made that very
clear yeah but he doesn't have to go
that's a nice gift yeah that's true he
won't go and you do you know the worst
part is certain people i would want to
invite you have to ask for their address
but obviously you should have something
where there is a text
i think that's a really good thing to
have to somebody if you
a text invite like hey i've set this up
so you don't have to give your address
um i can do everything through the phone
if you let me take a picture of the
invitation and send it to them some
somehow they can click a link or
something there should be a way to do it
through text interesting yeah and then
you don't have to ask people for their
address all the time yeah inevitably he
says no but like seinfeld is you know i
don't know how much a gallon of milk
cost rich right
right so you know he doesn't even
understand that like
fifty thousand dollars is not how much
people's yeah spend he might send me a
calculator right
right
no you won't he'll probably just say no
and not send you anything ah send you a
seinfeld dvd set yeah yeah i'd have to
phrase it right like hey jerry i know
you hate these things but uh my lady
made me do it or i'd make something i'll
invite him with friends and they had
like if you if you want to
uh no presh yeah
all right yeah you should invite them
you're friends with him
ah i'm scared when's the last time you
talked to he won't go but you still
invite i know there's plenty let me know
about who wouldn't go all right all
right it's not bad lou thank you that's
true if you're gonna invite ozzie you
can invite jerry
yeah right really of course you would
invite ozzie sure why not i mean him and
his wife have been very nice to me and i
would love them to come do i think they
would no it's like you're in la
yeah
all right that's not bad not gonna fly
here for my wedding also i need a reason
to text him even though i did fly out
there for his birthday
[Laughter]
when was the last time you texted him
it's been a minute wow yeah i'm
stressing you out a little a little bit
yeah
why don't you ask him to be your best
man
but i feel like i'm floating away from
that shore a little bit with jerry i got
him back in there but it's okay you're
not an opener like you're you're out
headlining doing theaters you're at the
lincoln theater in dc i saw you got that
right like you're doing these bigger
gigs so it's like that's kind of the
natural it's healthy yeah but it's also
healthy to keep a friendship alive sure
but yeah it's starting to feel like that
beep beep beep
and you're thinking like but you already
know each other yeah you could sit down
you've had dinner with him yeah good
point and i think it's kind of nice
tonight we can still be friends that i
never text because then he doesn't have
to worry about me you know it's it's
almost more close to not bug each other
no you know closeness is like or fake
clothes
don't say bug each
angle on the pictures or videos i want
to see them
it was clearly the booster am i right
yeah yeah something like that yeah
you're right
all right that's not bad yeah i think i
think yeah inviting him to the wedding
is probably the most who's your best man
my brother oh yeah it's fair fair choice
you don't want to make a comment now
they fight over it it's a whole thing
yeah
sean patton is officiating
that's fine oh yep sorry i queefed
but uh yeah it's gonna be a real hoot
do you think jerry would fly to new
orleans to go to your wedding no no not
in a million not even if he was doing a
gig in new orleans the next time
yeah he would get the hell out of dodge
yeah i don't think jerry would leave the
house
not to mention that white trash cousins
would be like jerry can i get a photo
you know i love you on oh he would hate
that he would hate at weddings where
he's stuck at a table it must drive him
crazy oh
my god everybody coming up to him yeah
he's at collins wedding though i saw him
there all right that was in new york and
that's colin exactly he loves colin yeah
it's colin yeah but my family would bug
this [ __ ] i love comedians getting tea
you know all that [ __ ] that would ruin
it yeah
how how have your parents reacted to the
wedding coming up are they excited or
are they still dead inside they don't
care
they don't care at all they uh do they
like your fiance i think so it's hard to
read it's fun watching her interact with
them because she'll tell this long story
and open up and be vulnerable and
they'll go what was that you know and
i'm like you see you see what i went
through it's fun seeing a normal human
interact with these psychos right yeah
because make your dad make a speech
it would never you don't think dad's
gonna make a speech he might do a little
thing i i'm not a comedian yeah that's
cute very proud of my son marv
exactly
yeah it wouldn't be pretty but uh they
like her i mean you brought the whole
wedding to new orleans
that was her idea why is her family from
there too or no she's from uh gray old
massachusetts
so she's like ah it's no fun there let's
go somewhere fun she's just not she's a
nice person very nice thoughtful lady
good egg yeah you're gonna do it on
bourbon street close
it's right off like two blocks off in
the french quarter is it during mardi
gras no that just happened
that'd be great if you got married
at mardi gras be the weirdest like a
bunch of beads
awful new orleans music oh come on
[ __ ] the worst
no it's gonna be fun new orleans music
is [ __ ] horrendous they're gonna have
crawfish
all the good po boys po boys gumbo you
name it one night of the week you're
doing it it's a thursday so people can
still do gigs that's how little
self-esteem i have
thursday weddings they won't come during
the weekend because they got to work
there yeah they're in denver they're
sunday's a good day dallas
sunday's a good day for a wedding people
do on sundays usually don't they
where's the saturday friday or saturday
yeah saturday is like the day for a
wedding but that's also the most
expensive day
you could do it on a sunday afternoon i
guess but yeah yeah friday saturday
saturday is the wedding yeah because
your community and sunday is a good
night no but you want to party and then
you got to go to work on monday with the
comedians don't
we yeah but i mean for everybody that's
not a comedian welcome
we're doing thursday and if you want you
can do the weekend in new orleans you
know make a thing out of it destination
wedding is a little different yeah
that's right get away with it and
probably people probably will if there's
a lot of people traveling
then you know i don't think that's that
big of a deal because it's not like
you're doing something if you're
traveling for the wedding it kind of
makes sense i have an idea
you you shoot like a little documentary
about it and you say to jerry how funny
would it be if you were like the limo
driver oh that's fair and they then they
the thing back and you lean back and you
go um destination sir
it's not bad jerry i want to pitch you
something oh god and i want to hit you
with the title first ah
comedians in cars getting
married
a special we can split the rights on it
we'll put it with your stuff what do you
think
comedians and cars getting married if
you liked if you liked my pitch
about you teaching me how to drive in
the middle of times square yeah you're
going to love this chair this will be a
great way to get them back i haven't
texted him in three months and i've come
back with a [ __ ] pitch of him driving
a limo
yeah yeah comedians in cars and then
send another text that says parentheses
wait for it and you should and then
another text that says getting
married and you put the script in the
text of what he would say
and it's him like looking back through
congratulations well there's nothing
funnier than that partition going down
and revealing it's jerry and he's got
the little cap on yes come on yes that's
comedy yeah yeah that's fine where to mr
normand yes
yeah and make it fast yeah and then i
get to push the thing back up oh yeah
he's doing the thing where he lifts up
trying to catch up or you can say no tip
for you yeah oh yeah
yeah and go like this
yeah you get a couple of references
we're gonna have a bunch of soups
no soup for you oh yeah
that's actually better jim yeah there's
a couple of gays coming to the wedding
not there's anything wrong with that ah
that would be fun yadda yadda
another one you never saw it no but you
could say hey maybe jerry you can come
out and lead us in an elaine like dance
oh that's fine little kicks that's fine
hey we've all got a bet going on as to
how fast you can get us to the wedding
hey let's go
not bad he'd like that yeah you throw a
buck in his lap i don't want to say what
i did in the backseat
that's fun thank you that's fun in my
vows i'm doing a full cramer so that'll
be that's good i like that
are you writing your own vows uh we had
this big vow talk and she's like i'm
nervous cause you you're comedian blah
blah does she see you on stage
be very confident but i just said what
did we do no vowel she was like thank
god i was freaking out i was so much
pressure so i was like great no vows
you're not doing i like that ah nobody
wants to hear that horse [ __ ] oh yeah
vows eat ass yeah i cares blah blah blah
forever got it i think people like why
are you going white people around the
world divorced in a month
[ __ ] needs vows i'm with you so sean
is just going to be like you you and
you're going to be like
zing zang get get get it hitched hit the
dance floor
yeah i mean you could just have a party
you don't have to have a wedding well
the ladies like it she got a dress yeah
floral arrangement
who would i want to do but by the way
like big celebrity quinn would be good
he's not he's not all no he's not a big
enough celebrity no none of us would
know when to say i do that mumbling
idiot
yeah he's [ __ ] well he's all he can't
hear anything anymore how was his
wedding
one of the best i've been to really yeah
i was your first one for that yeah it
was awesome
it was really nice yeah
yeah it was a lot of fun but mark like
i want i kind of want to set her down
and say that
she doesn't need to worry that you guys
should write your own vows
and she doesn't need to worry because he
like you're a public speaker and all
but you're not like the most
emotionally in touch
i think uh
she would probably have like these
beautiful vows that nobody would see
coming and she'd knock it out of the
park and you'd go like
weddings am i right
i'd be afraid to i'm afraid that i would
get nervous because sometimes i
pronunciate my worms
it's fun
hopefully ricky will be in the audience
for that one
it's funny when i propose i don't know
if i told you this but i got that on one
knee and i went i love you and she was
like yeah come on that's what i mean
like yeah she really doesn't have to
worry about you
doing better with the vows than her it
would be nice to see him read his vows
though because he would probably have to
be like really genuine and be good to
see mark do that he'd have a lot of
trouble with it i would i'd get a jew
joke in there it would be awkward yeah
i'd be like why why is he doing that why
does he feel the need to do that
yeah yeah it's a
i don't know i think it's better without
a tough time making eye contact oh i
still killing her in the eye no i
understand that yeah so wait that you're
not going to do vows he's just going to
say i now pronounce you the [ __ ] does
that work without you saying anything i
think the guy sean patton will do a
little this and that we do the ring we
go i love you
we kiss that's it yeah that's it it's
quick and easy go like you you may kiss
the bride and you go yeah you want to i
don't know yeah because if you don't get
vulnerable you get [ __ ] on hey that was
pretty stiff up there yeah big hunk of
coal and then if you get too vulnerable
your friends have that on you for the
rest of your life oh you love her
you big [ __ ] queef
you can't win you're worried about
friends you're worried
you're worried about professing your
love to your wife because your friends
will think you're a queef yeah
yeah i guess that's true yeah but i will
say thanks a lot i'm kevin hart at the
end
yeah you have to yeah yeah and praise
allah yes exactly
comedy yeah
try to sell some shirts yeah right
would your vase get an invite to yours
i think so i think you're at that point
yeah i do like ricky very much and uh
plus he probably won't come overseas for
it and he'll be a good gift giver yeah
but he might be here in new york and i
do like jane very much yeah so yeah i
would probably consider inviting uh
uh gervais he might think it's a little
bit weird
but i would ask him he's also been
helpful to me with other stuff he's been
a
a good
friend he did the opening of my special
helped me out a lot if you were to get
married
i would say the best timing
for you to get married would have been
around the irishman because then you
might have been able to sneak an invite
into the de niro bob is gonna get an
invite anyway he is he's inviting me to
his christmas party what i've been to
his christmas party holy but that does
it but that was a while back it was a
few years ago but he hasn't had one
since then he's going through a divorce
but he had a he would drive his with his
family introduced me to harvey keitel or
no christopher walker so he's getting
one harvey yeah he introduced me he's
getting one yeah you're going to be okay
yes i said
so bobby's getting one yeah bob d will
get one that's awesome yeah he will come
but i mean
who cares maybe you'll get some uh
a gift from him box it or he'll go like
he'll go like i mean
bob
this isn't as as great a gift as i
thought he'd be like no these are the
jewels from the belt
the gift of a multi-millionaire is a
very rare item
man i loved your vase we got to get him
back around uh yeah i hope he's back in
town you know i'm right i mean we've
connected a little bit but uh i don't
i've never hung out with him i'm sure he
would like you on the show we should
have
yeah maybe that'll be the next uh
he loves doing the show with voss yeah
oh he loves voss yes he does he
requested rich which was weird because
that those words have never been put
together in a row before yeah exactly
requested rich nobody involved in this
show has ever requested rich